you've said you want to do good work
because you meet people
hardcore fans that have tattoos of you
on their body that's true yeah and you
say this is motivating you
to continue to do good work why yeah
well because you know i'll find
somebody's arm and they'll have it
permanently inscribed or they'll have my
likeness on their body and i think
i can't put out an album that sucks
because then they're going to go why did
i do that
right you know i'm going to cut off my
arm i can't believe i did that i was so
stupid
that would have to be a really bad hour
your uh food is a big theme for you
that's true yeah why do you know why
you're i mean are you just hungry when
you write
songs you know i i don't write so many
food songs anymore but in the 80s i
wrote a lot of songs about food
maybe because i was a starving artist
for so long and i was sort of food
obsessed i thought food was funny
but the the nice perk is now i can
write off all the food that i buy
anything that i eat i can write off on
my taxes
right it's research it is research i
might write a song about a bagel so you
never know
yeah so i gotta eat this chicken pot pie
right now
uh your first job i thought this was
interesting was and i never
i didn't even know this job existed and
it sounded like a joke but it's true
your first job was an accordion repo man
yes
yes this is the real thing an accordion
repo man explain how that's a real thing
okay well and then leaves
and he knows what i'm talking about his
daughter's taking accordingly it's true
yes indeed well explain accordingly what
happens is when you take accordion
lessons generally the parents aren't
obligated to buy an accordion that's a
major expense uh so they they the
the the school will loan you the
accordion so your kid can practice
now if you stop taking lessons and you
don't return the accordion
they call for accordion repo man so this
was your actual job was to go to
people's homes
you were given the address and the name
and you would knock on the door
and say give us back the stinkin
accordion right now i bet you the kid
was upset but the parents were probably
joyous they're like here here you go
thank you very much
they kick it out the door we are we are
the easiest job in the world
uh wow and now okay this is interesting
accordion has played a big part in your
life
and it is you did mention andy's
daughter mercy plays the accord she's a
big fan of yours she plays the accordion
yes
it's really cool with night man my own
daughter is uh taking according to your
daughter
well she i promise out of the blue she
asked me to take accordion lessons so
i've been uh tutoring her as well it had
nothing to do with the fact that you've
built your life around an accordion
how random that the 13th but the nice
thing is we know that our daughters will
never be like with the popular kids
right that's really nice would have the
peer pressure you're not hanging out
with that accordion gang are you
that's a bad lot uh you're delving into
our world a little bit
uh in uh in the talk show world yes you
are the new band leader
on comedy bang bang that's true i'm very
very happy about that thank you very
much
thank you these guys will teach you
everything you need to know you know
um i'm so happy to be on the show i mean
i i've got the sold out world tours i've
got the grammys i've got the platinum
albums but the one thing
the one thing i've always wanted was to
be somebody's sidekick on a low-rated
cable show that's the one thing
i've always wanted so it's all right
true
a dream come true it is
andy andy leaves every night weeping i
can only assume tears of joy oh
absolutely yeah i could ask him but i
never bothered